so I'm just gonna take a wild guess and
say the comments in the last video I did
Thor the dark world are probably not
very positive I'm also going to take a
guess that people are going to say well
what did you want what were you actually
looking for Captain America the Winter
Soldier is what I was looking for this
is a sequel that had a previous film
that was good and did a lot more with
its premise than anybody would probably
give him credit for and the sequel dives
even further into it it takes the drama
it takes the characters it takes the
story and it ups it to 10 when this film
came out nobody was expecting much yeah
it'd be fun ok let's go and see Captain
America can do his thing you know it's
not Avengers but I'm sure we'll be good
everyone was blown away by how much work
and effort went into this one the
development the twists and turns the
action holy smokes this is actually a
great comic book movie Captain America
returns in modern-day Washington DC
where he finds he's still having trouble
fitting in but not in the ways that you
think it's not the teehee ha ha what's
this thing I don't recognize it's him
trying to deal with the fact that a lot
of people he knew are gone it actually
opens with him visiting his old
girlfriend who's mentally and physically
fading away and you know what it's kind
of a tearjerker this is a woman who was
really likable in the first film has her
own show right now and then suddenly to
see her like this it said you really
friggin feel something for this but
that's not where it stops shield it
looks like it's being taken over by the
same people that tried to stop Captain
America in the first film Nick Fury is
dead and the captain is told not to
trust anybody
so he goes rogue he gets a few people to
join them including Black Widow and it's
a chase to not only outrun shield but
also stop that evil organization now
known famously as Hydra
while also trying to figure out the
story behind their newest weapon the
Winter Soldier I think most of the
people know what the story is behind
this guy but I'm not going to ruin it ok
so this is about as standard a filler in
between plot that you can get the idea
of being chased down by the people you
work for is recycled the evil
organization from the first film
literally recycled a lot of these
characters you've seen before some from
their own TV show yeah
this seems about as recycled as you can
get but again in this movie it's not the
subject it's the delivery the atmosphere
and the pacing is so good that whenever
there's a new twist or turn it feels
like a big deal you're surprisingly
really invested in what's going on with
a character that a lot of people found
kind of uninteresting originally because
it knows what to talk about to make him
interesting it talks about how he has a
hard time fitting in it talks about how
he has a hard time figuring out who's on
his side and who isn't it takes the fact
that he is such a Boy Scout to its
advantage because he likes working for
people and he likes doing good the idea
that he hasn't been doing good or is
gonna continue not to do good is
something that would make him feel
really bad and you would feel the
turmoil in that he's fighting for
something you know he would fight for
and hey you would probably fight for -
there's a scene with Garry Shandling
that's actually a creepy scene yeah a
creepy scene with Garry Shandling
somehow this movie made that work and
when you do find out who the Winter
Soldier is it creates a lot of emotional
baggage it's interesting because you
feel their connection and that's what
this movie does it takes all this
standard stuff and you feel for it they
know the right elements to focus on they
know where to put the emphasis it's also
nice to see Black Widow and Captain
America working as a team yeah she still
hasn't gotten her own movie and clearly
she deserves it but if we're not gonna
get it anytime soon the more we can see
her the better and she's great as always
if I did have one nitpick and it really
is an if akai say I could have used a
little bit more with the Winter Soldier
don't get me wrong it's good but I think
because the rest of the film was so
strong and I was so invested I wanted a
little bit more of a rivalry there now
you do care but not as much you do a
rivalry between someone like Batman and
the Joker or Superman and Lex Luthor and
I know those are different kind of
relationships but those also made the
film's feel so much bigger and I wanted
this to feel as big as possible because
hey it kind of got on the right step
this could be one of the great big grand
comic-book movies but I think because
the relationship can't be delved with
too much because of all the are things
going on it's
holds back a little bit from that but
again it's a super big nitpick
everything else in this movie is really
really solid I'm actually amazed at how
good they made this it clearly was just
supposed to be a filler film but they
did their damndest to make it as amazing
as possible this is taking the idea of a
superhero and developing him even more
even one that a lot of people didn't
find that fascinating it took something
standard and it made it intriguing
that's what a good sequel is supposed to
do good action good story good
characters it hits everything
Suda because it's one hell of a ride